if there was a technology a quarter
million years ago that took a primate
and edited two parts of the genome to
make us who we are somebody with some
intelligence had to do that and it
wasn't us that was not Evolution
Evolution doesn't happen in an edit it
takes millions of years and that was two
edits to diff two different parts of our
genome that are clear that no scientists
can dispute exist they just don't want
to talk about why it happened since that
time we have not seen evolution in
ourselves is the answer that there's
another species from another planet or
from this planet that maybe is still
here somewhere that we don't know about
what the f is junk DNA junk DNA are
sections of your genetic code that have
no information which to me in the
Perfection of this human body there's no
room for Junk if you're programming
something and there's certain code that
you don't need anymore you turn it off
so at the time if we feel that there was
an edit it's as if you had a line of
computer code and somebody took a
portion of it and censored it